let's start with sunday night football
bears packers for the packers for aaron
rodgers that's about as close to a
perfect game as a quarterback can have
that's really the quarterback equivalent
to a perfect game
on the bear side i do not know trubisky
he probably starts with a raft on april
29th at this point where do the bears go
from here rodney
they got to make some changes they got
to make some um some big changes they
don't have a quarterback they don't have
an offensive line uh matt nagy has
failed the chicago bears ryan pace has
failed the chicago bears after ryan pace
the general manager screwed that
mitchell trubisky up pickup they should
have fired him so the bears are going to
have to blow things up they're going to
have to start over
if they want to contend in the future
well here's what matt and aggie said
after a difficult loss and what's been a
difficult stretch now five straight
after a pretty smooth start for the
chicago bears here is their head coach
every freaking coach on the on the staff
every player better wake up and start
start understanding where we're at have
some personal pride have a freaking
sense of urgency know where we're at
have some pride into who we're playing
for and why we do this
and uh and then and then go find a way
to win as a team
that's my challenge to every single
person in that building this week is
that
and and so uh yesterday was flat out
embarrassing
um and and uh our guys know it i'm not
telling you something they don't know
they know it but that performance
yesterday um
is uh is ridiculous and and and can't
happen and and obviously that starts
with me
he said it he said it best it starts
with him it does start with him but also
something very disturbing happened
yesterday that
it was just really bothersome to me the
fact that the bears defense wasn't
playing hard they flat out quit now that
was the first time i i could really
admit that the bears actually quit on
the field it's the defense um eddie
jackson and those guys you just didn't
see them they didn't want to tackle um
they just flat out quit quit jack
is there anything to when the team
doesn't believe in the quarterback
doesn't believe in the leader to where
offensively defensively the star players
just start to lose the belief start to
lose the trust and then you start to see
some of the quit you're talking about
they just don't believe in trubisky and
it trickles down from there
i'm almost thinking they don't believe
in trubisky they don't believe in matt
nagy and when
when players start stop believing in
their head coach then all of a sudden
they find reasons not to play hard they
protect themselves from getting injured
they don't go that extra mile they don't
come in early and do all the necessary
things to prepare themselves for the
following week and then all of a sudden
you get you get separation you get guys
talking in the locker room you get you
know the offense versus the defense and
and then you just start to get the
divide but matt nagy was right it starts
with him he has to have this team a lot
more prepared and the bears they just
they just don't have enough on the
offensive side of the ball
after being there last night i got a
whole new respect for aaron rodgers and
what he's been able to accomplish over
his career i don't think he gets enough
credit for what he does in the
environment in which he does it i mean
this is late november football right so
it gets weather-wise gets a lot worse
from there
it is freezing cold it's that cold gusty
wind and it's the winds blowing hard
enough to where it's affecting passes i
don't have any doubt in my mind that it
was affecting trubisky's passes and then
you watch aaron rodgers play and it's
perfect it's like he's completing every
pass touchdown after touchdown couldn't
look any more comfortable looks like
it's 80 degrees and sunny like he does
it in the hardest conditions in football
week after week year after year and i'm
not sure we give him enough credit just
because it's what he's always done he's
been there his whole career has been
there his whole life but man it's tough
up there in green bay wisconsin and
there's no excuses to be heard
you know it's funny because we sit back
and we always talk about aaron rodgers
we always talk about how great he is but
yet i feel the same way you feel like we
don't talk about him enough and i don't
know i mean but he's got one super bowl
ring
yep one
so that's probably the reason because
individually i mean he's putting up the
numbers the stats and all those
different things but you know when you
start talking about the all-time greats
you know the all-time greats have to win
multiple super bowls and i think this is
a big year for aaron rodgers they're
gonna have to do a better job of getting
aaron jones more involved in his offense
look i love devonte adams i think he's
fantastic but if they want to get take
that next step and get to the super bowl
they're going to have to be able to run
the football they're going to have to be
able to create mismatches and they're
going to be have to be able to play well
on defense and be able to stop the run
that's that's what you know what's
really holding them back defensively
rogers turns 37 this week he's playing
the best football of his career he's
playing like that 2011 2014 mvp versions
of himself
and matt lefleur came in and at first it
was a little
you know whose ideas are going to win
who's going to be the alpha here and
they found a way to make this
partnership work i don't know how
specifically it has worked i think there
was to some degree aaron's going listen
coach
i've been doing it at this level longer
than you have and that's just the facts
he has been operating calling plays
checking at the line of scrimmage longer
than coach lefleur has and once they had
a mutual respect for each other it has
just taken off there's been a newness a
new freshness to aaron rodgers a new
energy about him and they're dominating
on the offensive side of the football
here is their head coach matt lafleur
after a big win on sunday night football
are you light years ahead of where you
were a year ago at this time offensively
yeah i i mean
it certainly feels that way however we
know that you're only as good as your
last performance and so we've got to
continue to get better and find ways to
get better otherwise you guys are going
to say we stink so
um it's week to week in this league and
and we've got to continue to dig and and
make sure that we're doing everything in
our power to get better and better and
better
i think matt lafleur came in and it
wasn't i don't think it was a struggle
of power i think as a young coach he
wanted to come in show aaron rodgers his
you know his respect and you know how he
views aaron rodgers but at the same time
you're trying to win over a locker room
and it's tough to do because you don't
want to step on aaron rodgers toes but
yet you want to be able to you know to
let him know kind of what your
expectations are so i thought he's done
a really good job
of coming in really managing the
situation and it really takes for aaron
rodgers to be open-minded and i think
this year more so than any year that
i've seen aaron rodgers you talk about
the energy i talk i call it positive
energy because for so many years aaron
would always mope and always would say
negative things and sarcastic things
he's like he's a changed person he's
different his energy is different so
when he comes off to these young guys
these young guys are more willing to
accept aaron rodgers because he's a lot
more patient with him
i agree with you and when you go watch a
packers practice it is one of the most
unique looking practices ever because
it's like it almost feels like aaron
rodgers is the head coach you know it's
like the whole practice just revolves
around him and he sort of creates a
practice to exactly what he wants so
there's certain drills but he'll just
stand there and literally it is a trash
can down the field and for the entire
period it could be 15 20 minute period
all he's doing is just throwing balls at
the bucket because he knows that the
offense is just all about hitting that
spot but he's just throwing balls in the
bucket doesn't look like he's working
hard at all you know it looks like the
easiest practice that you'd ever see at
the nfl level but aaron knows what he
needs to get right and i just think it's
just taken time for lefleur to go if i
buy into what aaron wants to do
aaron may buy into what i want to do and
you just start to see those trusting
moments like when aaron points you know
don't throw a touchdown
first thing he does is points over to
the sideline points right at lefleur and
says that's the play call that's exactly
it when they find this flow this can be
a dangerous dangerous offense i think
you're starting to see them get healthy
hopefully lazard comes back healthy i
know he took a big shot in sunday night
football davonte adams is back he's
having one of the biggest years of his
career and he missed two games two big
games with the hamstring injury and his
stats are absolutely off the charts nine
touchdowns in the last six games is what
they've had i mean they are really
rolling offensively let's get to kansas
city speaking of teams that are hot
right now offensively the kansas city
chiefs tyreek hill he just went off in
that game yesterday
it was unbelievable because when todd
bowles and the tampa bay buccaneers they
played against the rams you know todd
bowles said back in zone coverage and
jared goff absolutely picked them apart
bing bing bing all the way down the
field so then he comes out and says you
know what we're going to do something
different we're going to play man-to-man
we're going to have carlton davis stick
the most explosive fastest receiver in
the national football league and not
only will he guard him he's going to
guard him by himself and i'm like okay
you saw the first touchdown he like what
is he doing he's 10 yards off he's
playing 10 yards off and tyreke hill
still beats him down the field if you're
playing 10 yards off off coverage let
the guy catch the 10 yard out cut nobody
cares about that but you cannot give up
anything deep and that's the problem
that i have if you're going to play man
to man be fair to i know todd bose as a
defense coordinator you want to
challenge your guys and i i get it but
you also it's your responsibility as a
defensive coordinator to make sure that
they're in a position to be successful
and going one-on-one i wouldn't put
jalen ramsey one-on-one with tyreke hill
all over the field so i just think the
game plan could have been better in the
second quarter toward the latter part of
the second quarter he switched started
keeping two safeties back and then it
forced patrick mahomes to stay patient
and dink and dunk when you're playing
against the kansas city chiefs
you can't give up big plays you have to
stay patient defensively and you have to
know who you're going against is it
travis kelsey he should be doubled tyrek
hill should be doubled all those other
guys miko hartman and robinson take your
chances with them but you cannot give up
big plays to those guys i just named
andy reid does such a masterful job of
sort of where's waldowing tyreek hill
where you just never know where he's
going to line up and he motions him
brings him across the formation gives
him the ball on those end of round plays
and just lets him go beat the corner to
space uh brings him in motion then
throws it to him going back across the
field like just having like you said
kelsey and tyrique uh and you have so
many weapons on that office not le'veon
and elaire it's like there's so much for
you to think about and hardman you i
think you just get distracted by looking
at all the diamonds and before you know
it tyreek hill is beating your
cornerback by 10 15 yards down the field
and to some degree
i think we as an nfl community make the
same mistake that talent evaluators make
when we start talking about who the best
receivers in football are
i don't think it's about being 6'5 225
pounds running 4-3 i think it's about
can you win every single play and i
don't see any receiver in football that
wins on every single play he doesn't get
the credit he deserves as a route runner
either this guy is open he wins
contested ball situations and he is
always always always behind the defense
and he has the perfect quarterback to
deliver him the ball uh when he's there
wide open let's get to bruce hold on
hold on hold on jack
yeah yeah yeah yeah go ahead rodney no
no no no go go with bruce erin's that's
that's where i want to go yeah
you know as we always do you know
whenever we criticize somebody in in the
defense they're playing we like to get
them in on the conversation then we take
it from there so here's bruce arians on
their defensive game plan against one of
the best receivers in football tyrequel
but he had a man of man you know we
tried to get a safety to him if we could
you know he got kelsey on the other side
too so it's a lot of weapons but when we
did play man-to-man
uh patrick found him and they made some
really good plays
it's amazing they had so much money and
it's it's amazing to me because they
have so much money in that front seven
it's
just keep two safeties back and say guys
we're gonna take away the big play you
guys have to handle the run and all the
underneath routes but you you talk about
how great their linebackers were it's
not like they were all over the field
making plays shaq barrett he came in had
a strip sack in a red zone against
patrick mahomes and they end up scoring
off that but it wasn't like their
defense was just making plays and you
look at their defense they've been
giving up 20 plus points the last three
or four games so it's not like their
defense is great but everybody wants to
over hype them
rod if i said to you right now million
dollar bet give you the kansas city
chiefs or give you the field who would
you take for a super bowl
hey i said this last night to chris sims
i'm saying i'm taking kansas city
because
you know you're not going to stop kansas
city but it's certain things that you
have to do you got to be able to jam
tyreek hill at the line of scrimmage
he's the fastest guy in the national
football league but yet nobody jams him
nobody slows them down then defensive
coordinators want to go man to man with
him and it's like you no one in the
national football league can defend this
guy man-to-man and yeah travis kelsey is
a problem but there's times and
situations where you have to double him
but if i'm a free safety
i'm always shading over to the side of
tyreek hill because he's you know him
and travis kelsey they're the most
dangerous guys on that team other than
patrick mahomes
well they have the best quarterback
maybe of all time one of the best
fastest receivers to ever play in the
nfl and tyree kill one of the best tight
ends to ever play in the nfl and travis
kelsey an emerging star at running back
in elaire and then another you know
le'veon bell he was part of the killer
bees man and now when you hear the
stories about le'veon bell
being a new person in terms of just
tutoring elaire saying anything i can do
to pass down some knowledge to you i'm
in man like anything i can do to help
you if he has that kind of attitude you
know that andy reid's going to start to
feed him his touches be it in the
passing game be it in the running game
whatever it is that is such a scary
scary team coming down the home stretch
i'm with you i'm taking casey over the
field in a million dollar bet as well
even though i'd have nowhere near a
million dollars
as good as the kansas city chiefs have
been
tampa bay looked all kinds out of sorts
tom brady i don't think i've ever really
seen him look that confused playing
offense he's like at one point walking
over and whispering in abe's ear it was
just a really weird day why did he look
so confused you have any idea what's
going on there raj i just you know when
i when i look at tom and tom is a guy
that's typically in control of
everything kind of around him and to me
he's trying to appease too many people
he's trying to appease all his wide
receivers he's trying to appease his
tight ends he's trying to appease his
coach he's got so much pressure on him
and he doesn't look relaxed and it looks
like he's putting so much pressure on
himself to be something that he's not
they're asking him to throw the ball
down the field we know that tom brady is
a guy that likes to
get the ball out of his hands quick he
wants to run the football an occasional
trick play even when they go empty sets
he wants to get the ball out of his
hands quickly he doesn't want to hold on
to the ball and throw the ball down the
field that's not him especially at 43
years old he's a different guy and what
teams are doing in kansas city did they
came after tom and they didn't care if
he held the ball they didn't care if
they got rid of it quickly they came
after tom and they went and then they
stopped having a little bit of success
with that then they started playing some
zone and some man coverage and tom in
the second half started making some
plays but you cannot give kansas city a
21 to nothing lead or whatever it was
and expect to be able to come back
because they're just too good of a
football team
those are the facts and and the reality
is that now tom has found himself in
another coach quarterback controversy
because you have all these conversations
bouncing back and forth between whose
offense is it is it aryan's offense is
it brady's offense is it a blending of
the two who's calling the plays who's
checking at the line of scrimmage and
it's all good when you're winning and
it's all bad when you're losing and now
that they're losing that's exactly what
it is bad so here was tom brady when
he's asked about his head coach bruce
arians right after the game
there's been some folks that have had
some chatter about you know you still
look like you're running someone else's
offense one of your former teammates
even said on tv that he thinks that you
need a new head coach what do you make
of all that noise
no it's just the external noise that
when you're losing you know that's what
you deal with so
uh
you know i love playing for for the guys
that i play with the coaches the whole
organization has been unbelievable and i
think what uh
you know it's got to go out i certainly
have to do a better job the last four
weeks of the year
so appreciate it have a good week
and tom is really good about
ignoring the outside noise but at the
same time he has to look at his play and
it just hasn't been what we expected i
mean when he's under pressure
and i've said this for years i've told
coach dungy this for years because i
played with brady for six years for six
years and i've been watching him and i
competed against him i remember playing
against him i think it was 2002 we
played against tom but tom under
pressure he's a different quarterback i
said that in different super bowls that
we covered when the patriots were
playing it's just who he is and now he's
43 he's even more paranoid if you go
around his knees he's throwing he's
getting rid of that ball and then him
just throwing balls up and guys dbs i've
never seen that before so you can tell
he just doesn't feel comfortable and and
you ask me the question is who offense
is this well it has to be tom brady's
offense because he doesn't have the time
to try to figure out everything that
bruce aaron's want him to do he has to
say you know this is what's comfortable
to me let's do these different things
and you look at their personnel they got
these big rangy guys that want to push
the ball down the field when he was with
new england he had wes welker he had
julian edelman he had these short small
possession type receivers and he
excelled with that so they got to find
some type of balance but he has to be
comfortable and stop trying to appease
everybody
that's a that's a really good point and
a b in theory can be that kind of slot
quick receiver that can always be open
but they just don't look like they have
any clue what the other one's thinking
right now it just they both tom wants to
get a b the ball a b wants the ball
desperately as he always does and they
just have no clue i've never seen a
quarterback in shotgun ready to get the
snap look over at his receiver and go oh
he has no clue what the play is have to
run from his quarterback spot all the
way out to the receiver spot and go like
this he literally whispered into a bee's
ear what the route was and you you're
looking at the db he's standing he's in
bumping around coverage he's four feet
away he probably heard the
route you have all of those kind of
things going on and even mike evans the
only person that he looks comfortable
throwing the ball to right now in my
opinion is grunk and gronk's not the
same grunk like he's playing great
football for his age and all those
things but he just can't quite run like
he used to am i wrong there rod
no you're not you're absolutely right
when i was watching um the game this
morning i was like you know what he
feels he only feels comfortable with
gronk and you saw like even mike evans
had one he laid it perfectly in his
hands and went straight through his
hands and you look at mike i love mike
evans i think he's one of the top
receivers in this league but you look at
his body language and the body language
is bad and the only way they're going to
have success this year is everyone has
to understand
we don't we can't care about the stats
it doesn't matter who gets a thousand
yards it doesn't matter who gets 70 80
catches if we if they want to win if
they want to go far in the playoffs you
got to put all those selfish ambitions
and those individual things that you're
trying to accomplish away it's all about
the team and that's the thing that tom
is trying to get you know get that
message throughout the locker room it's
about the team it's not about your
numbers if you want to win a super bowl
who cares if you have a guy
look we had randy moss in 2007 we went
undefeated 16-0 end up being 18-0 and
lost in the super bowl so
i think what they have to do is they
have to get back to running the football
with ronald jones ronald jones is a
really good player i think he's one of
the most underrated players and if you
saw that catch out of the backfield and
him take it up the i think it was the
left side of the um sideline and just
the speed the athleticism and the will
to get to the end zone that's who they
have to go through not tom brady
it's a team that's so damn talented it's
a team that like desperately it's almost
like they needed like a mid-season
preseason like they just desperately
needed a preseason something where they
can just get on the same page and
especially with ab joining so late down
the line i just think it's been so hard
and kind of messed up the flow of this
whole offense let's get to tom's old
team the new england patriots get a win
and somehow on life support they may be
but they are alive right now how did
they shut down kyler murray yesterday
when you watch that game
well you know the offense has been
struggling so coach belichick had to go
old school on them jack special teams
and defense and it was tremendous and
defensively they said hey we don't want
to give up the big play we're not going
to give up to big play and they didn't
give up the big play deandre hopkins had
five catches i think for 55 yards the
second thing is hey we cannot allow kyle
murray to run around and beat us with
his legs and they did an excellent job
and they rushed forward they had two
spies at times and there's just look
here's this is perfect four-man rush
and you got to get your hands up colin
murray is five eight he's a five-eight
quarterback so if you want to pressure
him get the pressure up you see chase
wanna [ __ ] he's up in the air you see
the corners the safeties they're playing
back they're giving them these quick
throws and things like that but they
have two spies right here making sure
that kyla murray and that was the
difference in the game he only was able
to rush for 31 yards and when you can
hold kyla murray and you limit his
play-making ability that's how you take
him away
it was it was really fun to watch the
way that belichick played kyler murray
even when he would bring pressure if you
would bring more than four if you would
bring six or bring seven there was
always guys that were just patiently
waiting they weren't really trying to go
sack them in the backfield they were
rushing and then they were breaking down
and just going come on like just daring
kyler to run and very rarely do you see
kyler look uncomfortable escaping but
that's the way he looked the whole game
even when he would try to peel out and
just do his big looping
russell wilson spin out there was
defenders just waiting layers of
defenders waiting for him and really the
only one or two times you saw him escape
when he tried to was when they broke
contain when somebody fell or tripped or
got blocked in a weird way that was the
only time that he ever really got out of
there for the vast majority of that game
they had him contain now on the other
side of the ball the patriots don't seem
to trust cam newton i mean that's that
seems problematic to me this is a
glorified wildcat offense they don't
want to let him throw and i don't know
that in today's nfl you can really make
a deep playoff run if you're not willing
to stretch your quarterback more than
eight or nine times a game
well that's why they're five and six
because you know they they have faith in
cam to a certain degree but he struggled
he's he's playing poorly right now and
you know he talked today about a uh you
know i'm not keeping it a win is a win
i'm not gonna make excuses for for
winning the football game but you're not
gonna win very many football games when
you can't throw the ball down the field
how many yards did he have like eight
was it 89 or something like that if i
remember correctly
yeah something like that he didn't even
pass yeah he didn't pass for even over
100 yards and that's disappointing
because now you're not affecting the
defense and arizona should be
let me tell you this this this loss
right here could cost arizona an
opportunity to make the playoffs i think
this this loss was huge because this is
a loss where you come in you expect to
win you got the patriots struggling on
offense up and down on defense and for
for you not to be able to come in and
beat the patriots that was a big loss
for the arizona cardinals considering
they still have to play some teams in
the division
yeah it was just one of those fun
belichick still got it kind of games
like arizona's all hot everybody's
thinking arizona's gonna go in there and
whoop the patriots as they're weak and
belichick just has that that trump card
that joker stacked at the bottom of the
deck and he can pull it out anytime and
that's why they're so sneaky man if they
can figure out a way to just get in the
playoffs get a wild card spot and
there's of course that extra playoff
spot now this year the added playoff
spot seven and so if they can sneak in
there then it just becomes week to week
if he can just the old in the hunt
in the hunt running out of ammo are the
new england patriots but they have
enough to let me say this let me say
this real quick they just gotta win one
game man yeah go ahead right
yeah i look at the miami dolphins too
and the miami dolphins they're one of
the worst
um russian teams in the national
football league and now you have tua
will he play will he not play you have
ryan fitzpatrick
and the mommy dolphins they're not going
to be able to just rely on the the
quarterback and the defense they have to
find a way to be able to run the
football consistently if they want to
make a playoff run
another team who's had just a terrific
ground game lately the cleveland browns
although baker mayfield yesterday he
proved a little something if he can be a
supplement of this running game like he
was and i understand it was the
jacksonville jaguars right that's that's
one of those games you can get a pro
football coming out
it's still pro football though and he
was finally throwing the ball around
look comfortable slotting it into some
places you back your mind you're
thinking is there no obj is that making
him a little more comfortable because
jarvis landry looked like that star
number one receiver as he did when he
first got to cleveland with no obj
yeah and it's funny even when obc
odell came i never looked at him as
being their number one receiver i always
looked at
um him as almost being their number two
receiver because i felt like landry was
that that security blanket that banker
may feel needed but this offense comes
down to nick chuck i mean if he can
continue to run and this kid can play
football he's a top five running back
he's excellent
and then you have an excellent
compliment in kareem hunt and kareem
hunt is an excellent receiver out of the
backfield we've seen that his rookie
year he can run in between the tackles
he provides them with a lot of energy
and a lot of physicality i love what
cleveland is doing
before i wasn't a big believer but
they've won three straight they're
playing solid defense they're running
the ball they're physical and baker
mayfield he started rusty yesterday he
threw some balls some passes
in the red zone and they were high and
they were kind of off target but he
settled himself down and came back and
really played a good game really nice
corner out by austin hooper in the red
zone that he completed i like what
they're doing they're they're humble
it's not a lot of talking and not a lot
of friction i think kevin stefanski is
doing a really good job of just keeping
those guys focused on football and
that's what you have to do
i agree with you and it's a hard job i
think freddie kitchen's proved to the
football world how hard of a job that is
it's the cleveland browns now man this
is a team that was 4 and 44 from 2015 to
2017 it was they haven't had a winning
season
since 2007.
no winning seasons since 2007. they're
sitting there at eight and three right
now they've won three straight
i think we're losing a little bit of
perspective on the fact that this is the
cleveland browns and like baker mayfield
he may not be playing perfect but he
played pretty well sunday and he has
them at eight and three which is
something that about 30 quarterbacks
through the history of time haven't been
able to go in there and win any games so
i think we got to give this guy a little
bit of love for what they've been able
to do and i know it's been on the back
of chubb in that running game
you're right you're right you know it's
funny because we sit here and we laugh
at cleveland for years for being really
the laughingstock of the national
football league and they're doing
something unprecedented right now and i
do believe that kevin stefanski he's
writing that conversation with mike
tomlin brian flores as coach of the year
i think he's like i said before he's
done a wonderful job of keeping those
guys
just focused on football and not all the
other nonsense and this season is going
to come down to baker mayfield and what
he's able to do you know
will he continue to play not turn the
ball over they rely on the run game and
jarvis landry like you talked about he
was outstanding defense camp comes up
with a couple plays
i like what cleveland's doing they're
sitting there good in the five spot
yep there it is there's the playoff
picture on the afc side of course
in the division pittsburgh undefeated
that's what puts them in the wild card
let's hear from baker mayfield though
after a big win and what's really been a
big season and a surprise season for the
cleveland browns
i really feel like we left a lot of
points on the board i truly do uh i mean
there was a ton of missed opportunities
from just my perspective a lot of
misthrows um you know there's
only two things i hate more than missing
throws and it's
lying and skim milk and skim milk's just
water lying about being milk so uh gotta
make those throws
what
lying in skim milk because skim milk's
lying about being milk is that what he
just said did i hear that right i i
don't know i don't know where he was
going with that um but he said exactly
what i wanted him to say
you know it's funny and let me just tell
you this about players that love
football and he's a guy that loves
football you don't really bask in like
your success you know the thing that
he's probably driving home like man i
missed that throw it was too high that's
what you focus on you don't focus on the
success because you expect that as a
great player and i'm not saying he's a
great player but that's what he expect
he expect big things from himself but
that's what he's concerned about the
missed throes and you know what
i think he's gonna i think he's gonna
improve baker this is the most humble
i've seen baker he's focused and these
guys really look at him as being that
leader
i i can just tell you from personal
experience there's a big difference
between 22 and 25 you know like just as
a man you just you change a lot from 22
to 25 there's just that's a real
maturity and he's starting to get a
little closer to that 25 thing and i'm
with you i think you're starting to see
a little bit of that let's get to
somebody who is a great player king
henry derrick henry tennessee titans
they had lost round one to indy round
two they stormed into indianapolis and
they just from the very first snap of
that game were handling indy in every
single way and derrick henry could not
be stopped how did they do it
well you look at indianapolis deforest
buckner denico autry um
bobby okariki they were out against the
titans so
you know you're mike brabo you're going
out and saying three of their best
defensive players are out what are we
gonna do we're not gonna come out throw
the ball 50 times we're gonna run the
football and
i just tell you watching it they just
absolutely wore this defense down darius
leonard is an excellent running back um
excellent linebacker but he's more of a
sideline a sideline guy
so they ran the ball down the hill they
ran it toward the sideline derrick henry
is actually catching passes out of the
backfield i like what they're doing with
derrick henry and he looks fresh it's
not like he's even tired or he's hurt he
looks fresh but 27 carries giving him
over 25 carries that's how you frustrate
a defense that's how you wear a defense
down and then all of a sudden in the
third and fourth quarter these dbs are
looking like and even the linebackers
because these are fast athletic
linebackers oh my god we got to hit this
dude again we gotta hit this guy again
it just completely wears you out and it
frustrates you
and i know that this is the league where
we disrespect the running back position
and we make it all about the quarterback
and nobody wants to pay the running
backs and as soon as they get over a
certain age we're looking to draft young
and cheap and mid-round or late round
like that's just how the running back
position is handled in the nfl but
there's no question this guy's different
you look around the league there's
nobody else like him and defenders don't
want to touch him they don't want any
piece of them if he gets to the second
level they really don't want any piece
of him should he be in mvp consideration
like if you could take patrick mahomes
out of it would he be the mvp of the
league right now
it would be it's interesting so let me
ask you this let me ask you this because
that's a that's a really good question
so the two guys that really come to mind
for me
or maybe the three guys
outside of the quarterback will it be um
tyrique hill
who's another guy
i don't know man
no man patrick mahomes is the mvp this
this guy's played well but patrick
patrick mahomes is an mvp
but yeah he's definitely the deserved
mahomes is definitely there but it just
feels like you'd put three or four
quarterbacks ahead of him just based on
how we look at the nfl like aaron
rodgers he probably would slot in number
two before they would give it to derek
henry it's like what would you even have
to do as a running back what would you
have to do to win the mvp i don't know
that you could do more than derek henry
is doing right now i guess that's the
point
he may get close he cruised past the
century mark a week ago right cruised
but but i tell you this and and i just
want to mention this you know we talk
about the tennessee titans run game
and we got to give props i mean
obviously to the offensive line they've
lost some guys on offensive line but
these wide receivers man just how big
and how
just um
you know willing willing they are to
block these guys man aj
aj brown and corey davis they get in
your face they block you they're
blocking down on defensive ends they're
crack
blocking linebackers i mean they do a
wonderful job so everybody gets involved
in a run game it's not just derek henry
you see so many people that just
underestimate what aj brown's speed is
like he'll catch a slant in a db the
corner of the safety will take an angle
and they just miss they don't think that
a guy that big can accelerate like that
he's like t.o or something like terrell
owens when he hits the gas after he
catches it he is out the gate and even
if you do get a hand on him he's too
strong to physical
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports